Jim Parsons is in the building the actor
from the Big Bang Theory Sheldon and he
has nothing to promote I don't think you
came in
I really don't you'd have nothing just a
summer of nothingness it's true I don't
know I well I I could promote way in
advance a movie I just wrapped in
Atlanta called hidden figures about a
story of getting us into space NASA and
there were three African American women
who were instrumental in getting that
done but kind of didn't not kind of
didn't get any credit really until now
because of the times and what being what
they were and and that was really fun I
met Kevin Costner I worked with him he
was fantastic now what did you want to
know when you when you see Kevin cost
what did I want to know in a fanboy I
didn't want to know anything you didn't
know I really didn't go into it wanting
to know anything
i I mean I haven't thought about this
you're asking it but I know I normally
approach it with the very kind of I'm
not good at being like hi I'm Jim and I
love that I just I just don't do it I'm
better kind of keeping my nose down and
if things go well maybe we'll start
talking and and that's kind of that's
basically what happened we had to we
were in every scene together what did
you want to know from Costner from let's
say a previous movie or previous role
was there anything that you know no no I
mean I don't know I mean I would have
could have made up something like okay
did you in Susan Sarandon have fun on
boulderer I mean but that's stupid who
cares well but now you know what it's
like for fans when they come up to you
Oh completely no no go haha completely
different really it but boy I notice it
for me is like sports figures or news
people because like most of my viewing
pleasure is either sports or live news
we just did the up fronts for CBS and
there's all these people there that
you're like oh I've been watching you
for years actors and whatever and it was
lovely I turned the corner and basically
Shrikant the news people it was like
Gayle King and
Norah O'Donnell and John Dickerson and
they're all like hi Jim hello and I'm
like oh my god I just you I've watched
you every morning at you like come on
but that's what that's what gets me
going like those are I I do know how
people feel and they see because like I
watch you every day and said I'm talking
to Charlie Rose you know what about its
when's the last time is sports at you
know an athlete made you react that way
I'm not running into them as much I
don't even remember the last time I mean
the last sports figure I was talking to
was probably the tennis player Jeanne
Bouchard but like that started on such a
organic level before she was doing well
that like I wasn't that freaked out when
I met her you know what about who's the
person who reacted that way to you like
are there celebrities who know although
Daryl was really nice I just got to meet
him and that was a real thrill I was
saying this off camera off radio his al
Sharpton is remarkable it's room again i
watch news so but that's incredible and
that was that was that was pretty
exciting I'll be honest with you do you
do impersonations
not a one no not oh no yours are much
better than my but mine I'm not great no
no I mean you know fritzy's Marge
Simpson is great is that true they
didn't listen one bring her out okay Jim
polishes in studio this is really
exciting
I gotta have to tell homie about this
one I love Jim Parsons why did that
happen I mean what were you doing that
you just started going I couldn't really
do a wall that's a great question I was
watching The Simpsons and I started just
like kind of doing like South Park
characters and Simpsons characters and
different animated voices and I did that
for like a couple of friends and my wife
and they said you really sound like
Marge Simpson
cuz I really do the only one she's got
these two sisters that smoke along if
you go a little deeper
her sister stuff like this the Marge is
higher-pitched there's a smoking and
that's Julie Kavner right yes is that
right yes yeah yeah she's great huh so
you don't do any have you tried to do it
in person I imagine people try to
impersonate you yeah and a lot of them
are pretty effective at it to be honest
I've got a fairly has somebody done it
imitatable sound you
yeah well even on our show like uh Simon
Helberg on our show can imitate he's
very good at that and he can do anybody
within about ten minutes there's some
sort of ear you yes for it where it's
like a cadence and a rhythm and uh like
the pauses and whatever they're all just
right and he can do he can do anybody
he's a close friend so he doesn't
normally do it to me well you were on
Saturday Night Live
what last last year yes okay are two
years ago I don't remember this is my
favorite thing I've ever done Hollywood
related ever ever ever how they've met
Oh terrified terrified but there's part
of you that I mean you're in a good way
okay it really was yeah because a lot of
times you'll go after the fact you'll go
yeah that was fun but during the process
you're not having fun I the hardest part
for me was that lead you do the the the
first run-through like it I don't even
know what time like 9:00 till 10:00 and
then you do the final cut then you do
the live show at 11:30 what was hard for
me was the adrenaline of doing that
first cold dress rehearsal basically in
front of an audience
I felt honestly a tiny bit in my opinion
a little too relaxed going into the
other one like I felt I was better in
the dress rehearsal that may not be true
but like I was so like blinders on
because I was nervous and by the next I
kind of opened up and when I was like I
don't know that I need to open up I
should kind of stay focused I'm sorry so
that was interesting but they make life
so good for the host over there like it
is it is shot through a cannon and
summer theatre camp at the same time
it's just it's amazing and to be a part
of that process and watch them Lauren
taking things off the wall like okay
we're not doing this skit whatever
that's the other great he's like what
are your favorite skits that you
wouldn't want to see cut and I I listed
two or three that I really liked and I
said and one of them um I just loved as
his just so bizarre it's got like this
whole avant-garde thing to it he goes I
hate it and the rider was in there when
I'm so sorry
I'm so
sorry I said that and sure enough he
didn't keep a thing that I said I loved
you know which I appreciate he was like
he wanted to know and if he could help
me he would but he couldn't help me a
lot of times the artist is the last
person who should be talking about their
art completely completely it's somebody
who has to be honest with the artist you
say no no no no well it's like the funny
thing about chemistry on-screen I think
you see people all the time that are
better they get a long road not all the
time sometimes it works but who get
along real well in life or whatever and
it's just not that interesting sometimes
to watch them whereas you hear stories
all the time about people who have great
chemistry that they're like they're not
there they really didn't like each other
and so having fun I guess my point is
having fun and us get something I enjoy
doing isn't necessarily the best product
it's like well I don't care if you're
having fun
is it good but you get along with like
truly get along with everybody in the
Big Bang oh yeah we are or do you have
to have those moment ago we need to get
nine-year relationship going on to a
decade next season so you have moments I
mean this is a family it's a same as us
it very much it went on ten years my god
yes yeah wait a minute when did you
start your 10 still together uh we're
coming up on you're just like us then
week really debuted the same year I'll
get up in August of o7 for us oh I'm
sorry Arturo bow 7 for us and we were
September of us up yeah I've never
realized that Jim and you're five years
into appearing on the show your first
appearance was five years ago and I
think you're up to like six or seven
five years yes so he decade he did The
Tonight Show with Leno and you mentioned
us and that's when we got to hold you
the next day hundred born that day or in
kindergarten now yeah but I've been on
you meant to stay I remember coming in
that next morning and I had all these
messages like did you hear what Jim
Parsons said on Jay Leno and I'm going
laymen Jim who's Jim Parsons on his own
it made me very nervous when I heard
that I was gonna have to call in I was
like well because there's also this
thing too about and I think I've said
this to you before but uh suddenly
having to grapple and be a part of
something that you're enjoying it like
don't rob me of this what if this
haribol is very you know and that was my
biggest fear going
do it luckily it was a a very lovely
time well see again and there it is
there it is that's acting right there I
think yeah I think I'm protecting myself
I don't I don't want to say something
overly sincere and have you be cold
about it or something and so I have to
go maybe I'm not telling the truth you
know I would love to put that to the
test right now okay how you tell me
something very sincere and warm and then
all I'll try to this isn't gonna work
it's not no because I don't like needy
people and there's just you know when
someone telling y'all that you're needy
you're not needy at all
oh yes are you yeah a little bit
sometimes I needed and I need somebody
to say something nice these guys don't
do you know the only compliment I'll get
on the show okay hold on the only
compliment I get mm-hmm is when I say to
Fritzi after the show hey Fritzi well
done and then Fritzi will say you too
yeah that's it I do feel like in your 10
years going on 10 years the show has
evolved and there was before more of an
energy of people wanting to please you
and you don't feel that as much anymore
could you really not the running theme
of the show like that was kind of the
thing yeah while that's changed that's
change did you just insult those guys I
think I complimented that oh you do
everyone kind of grew up and went ah
whatever yeah no we're not going
anywhere
yeah he doesn't really have anybody else
they can do but you know what's gonna
happen though is when my contract comes
up here Oh ever will get varied and then
they're gonna be like is for campeón ago
she acient kidding me yes because I said
is we're having fun then I want to
continue I do this right so once that
comes up and then you know by sign
another contract uh like February of
2018 oh oh
I think it's earlier you said yeah oh it
is I think oh oh no that's my NBC deal
mm-hmm yes Fritzi once you brought up
the importance of fun I think the very
next day we brought in balloon
tell jokes yes unicorn you are we on the
same contract schedule because mine
would be up with our show in end of this
next season so 2017 like April pretty
close pretty close do you want to go out
together as the whole group the cast
like yeah like your your show yeah our
show we go oh you don't know I'd like
for you to remain on the air I mean but
you're gonna call it quits well here's
the thing you're gonna silicate this
show we're not gonna watch old sports
talk you know wait wait wait what that's
true don't you think somebody's gonna go
and find out who you are understand what
you're bringing to the park okay Wow mr.
syndication over here thanks Hollywood
okay yeah okay buzzkill and did you
really think they were gonna syndicate
this or have they well we're syndicated
around the country oh well that's that's
not what I meant
oh no do I we don't have RiRi peach like
if I to need a good watch she be not so
harsh I knew you were capable gaming
this is top mu gym portion you know our
shows our little stories and you can
wash it again like you would watch a
movie or listen to a song what if I did
like a half hour I cut this down to a
half hour what I just think it'd be that
be rough going we wouldn't get much done
well it'd be like skits like there'd be
like it you know Big Bang Theory has you
have certain scenes so you would just
have like four scenes and I don't have a
shout of planning that would take look
you have the privilege of three hours so
you can have a somewhat looser plan and
go into it and see what happened like
this we didn't know what we're going to
talk about but if you did 30 minutes
you'd have way too much planning we like
we have five minutes for LeBron we have
three minutes to curry after that you
know who you're rooting for we'll take a
break here oh no I got I got to kind of
regroup here a little bit do you yeah
they all hurt a lot I think sometimes
you disguise what what kind of pain
you're gonna what's up yes I gave a
great
ability to be able to say something and
I feel good when you say it
Oh until then I realized that you not
being nice uh I'm here but maybe to hurt
me no yeah well maybe I don't I don't
have a therapist fritz he's a little bit
upset because I mentioned to Darrell
Hammond that he does Jack Nicholson and
he said no I don't fritzy has spent the
last half hour looking for Darrell
Hammond doing Jack Nicklaus so a couple
of BIOS that suggested that it was one
of the ones that he does and then I had
just did a little search and he did a
couple second may not like he may not
like his impression of Jack Nicholson
but it makes it look like I messed up
the information that I cast not you have
messed it up before yes he's a Jim
Parsons regretting that he told Jay Leno
Donna loves this show not a bit and he
did that five years ago not a bit I I do
understand what you're saying where you
don't want to be part of something that
you enjoy yeah
watching because well you just said it
about sports I mean you've it's change
rightfully so it's change your
relationship with sports yes so you get
to be in the thick of it and it doesn't
allow you to always just be a fan do
this I do miss that yeah that high you
get that heartache that when something
that close to you and your team loses
and sometimes I forget that how this
affects fans and yeah you know that
sometimes you're not as sympathetic when
you see this but I went through that
when I was growing up of Who am I
rooting for I think you asked before so
apparently nobody yeah didn't you pick
Golden State no I didn't I didn't make a
pick you didn't I'm I think I'm rooting
for Golden State
oh you're I really like Steph Curry I
really like Steph Curry because he's to
me he reminds me of players that I used
to watch like in the 90s and stuff when
I was just you know the rockets or so
have two championships and everything
and I just feel like I'm making this up
you know hindsight but it's like I felt
there are more players like Steph Curry
like I don't know there's something very
team about him there's something very I
don't know maybe he's a horrible person
because
like it you know and it doesn't matter
to me if he's a good person or a bad
person as far as that goes but I don't
who was your favorite athlete growing up
hmm probably Hakeem because I was such a
big but I again I love tennis so much
and I loved like Navratilova and I loved
Chris Evert and I loved Pete Sampras and
so I don't know but obviously like would
you trade your career for Pete Sampras's
um I would like to experience that for a
while I like my life so no not
completely I guess but it would I would
if I picked any sports figure I would
take a tennis player probably a really
successful one I mean he's remarkable oh
yeah do you have that personality to be
a show-off like you have to be in
there's an entertaining part of you
whether what you say or how you play and
everybody is watching you do you have
that in you you know you played God on
Broadway yes so there has to be
are you still haunted by the memories of
playing God no it was a really good time
and I'm gonna go see Sean Hayes is doing
it this summer so I'm gonna go see him
do it
wait we just gave us a like a grimace
when I said you played God on Broadway I
just think it's a funny thing to say
even though it's true I mean it's really
weird to me that I played God on
Broadway it was lower case now in I was
gonna say encanta if you saw it you'd go
yeah yeah he played God but but but but
that's on the resume you know did you
take the role home with you you know
it's all great actors you know try now
you don't you know oh you weren't like
Daniel day-lewis or Christian Bale where
you take like you become now and with
this God it wouldn't have mattered
anyway you know it was like well that
was you but I didn't write it
no but you were playing you eye God was
playing me yeah God was playing God used
me yes and got his message out did
anybody react negative you can't imagine
was it blasphemous for people that you
were playing God the honestly the only
thing that vocally bothered people it
was only a couple of times
was his God's uh being okay with gay
people now of course most people were
just part of the show it was the only
time during the three-month run that two
different times I was screamed at from
the audience and would be like he would
he would basically being I would do the
part where he's like gay marriage is
okay like it doesn't bother me I don't
know what the words where it wasn't that
again I'm not a writer um but and some
twice somebody would scream all
garetty's to the point where I was like
I hope they don't have a weapon I like
how the person gonna charge the stage
yeah I wasn't saying and and the
craziest thing was like the day that the
Supreme Court passed marriage equality I
had I had one of my gay friends on
Instagram posted like congrats this is
great
still more to do and I looked at the
comments which why but in one of them
said it'll just never be enough will it
and I thought it'll never be a what what
that very night someone screamed gun
obscenity at me in that part and I
thought no not enough yet not enough yet
but how do you respond to a heckler well
it Tim I'm not like like you have
somebody like Darrell who I think would
be like ready and attune to something
and going to take off it I am like I'm
just I learned my words and I'm
presenting what is happening so I'm I
find myself I just keep talking before
you know I'm already moving on without
reacting to it in a literal sense that's
kind of too late at that point
especially in a play it's not it's not
stand-up the audience that was like Oh
which was I guess kind of nice at the
same time like well maybe they'll
protect me if he keeps moving me and
they take him out did they think it was
part did anybody think this was part of
I'm sure people did I'm sure they did
that was the hard thing the couple of
times it happened was going not only am
I not prepared to deal with it cuz I'm
not an improv guy and I just know this
words and what I not only you know do i
derail the story if I respond but I'm
supposed to be responding as god I don't
understand
and but the way it was set up as you
know you saw it was there were
interruptions bill yeah yes and I talked
to the audience the whole time and so I
think most people probably thought it
was part of the show until I didn't
respond to it and again by then I was
moving on and so they kind of you know
they're pretty malleable audience is
like okay we're moving on I thought they
would have written something in to sort
of protect you because that happened but
I mean after the first time yeah
Beverly did like if it comes up again
here's your response yeah to protect you
yeah no I did have one that I executed
myself which was not offensive at all
but there was a woman in I've got my
phone with me there was a woman in the
front row and she was videoed she was
like this right I mean I'm I'm closer to
her than Polly is to me right now
and I saw it happening and happening and
happening I finally just stood up and I
was like quit typing or whatever I said
I she was like I thought oh she probably
just sold herself I mean let me just
stood up on stage and yelled at her I
just you didn't ask for the phone no I I
was having vocal trouble at that point
and so I was on a low dose of steroids
and I was raging raging are you capable
of being mean mean yeah no I mean I
can't King Louis I'm not tall why sure
like you could this movie I just did and
I am NOT one of the good guys I come
around but I am I play a character who
is an impediment to one of the the
taraji Henson who's on yeah Empire to
[ __ ] she and I are I'm in her work
Department and I am kind of like her I
stand in her way
again again like not welcome and I had
to read that script like five times
before I finally turned to Todd who had
read it once and I go oh I I play
something with some sort of racist
tendencies he's like yes but it was so
hard to accept I was like well that
can't be what that means but that can't
be with and you
like oh no this is your role in this
story and and once I did accept that it
was really enjoyable because it was
really intense and it's nice it's nice
to get locked in a battle with somebody
even if from my own point of view
personally I'd be like not the side I
want to be on but but that's not the
point the point is the story annually
your voice a little bit because your
your voice Wells Pleasant II hmm no no I
will say something that's very different
and it's kind of it's very fun to do is
like because we tape our show live it's
kind of like being here like you're
talking to people that are both here and
there and so there's this but in most
scenes in the movies it's very I mean
you've been on the set you know it's a
much more intimate thing it's like you
could get as far away from me as you and
if I'm right here talking there could be
times you probably wouldn't be able to
hear us it's really bizarre
good mics I guess that's the point yeah
but you don't change your inflection
because your voice is it is a pleasant
sounding friendly voice well I don't
count lighting I don't cut I mean unless
it calls for it in some distinct way no
but I'm sure it changes depending on to
a degree because of the message I'm
sending in what I want what I'm trying
to do you know cuz I can get angry Y can
get angry does that mean I can get mean
in what way why don't you try me what
why see just happened just like that oh
that was so funny oh are you kidding me
that's acting Jim nothing but that's not
the same thing is asking a human being
can you be mean
oh no I'm not you feel that you've ever
been mean yeah you purposely were like
I'd like to hurt this person yes okay
well I probably have done that too yet
still it's like not a normal thing it
makes me uncomfortable to see people
hurt right yeah yo come on this is weird
in this conversation weird see guess the
mean line here you want to guess okay
all right what who said it yeah
wait wait wait wait what what am i
guessing do we want to take a break and
come back with guessed the mean line
okay okay this is a dinner last night
that you were invited to
you missed out I missed ya and I show
you how I did Ally had plans it was a
wonderfully as Jesse Tyler Ferguson he's
on Broadway and fully committed great
show he's my friend and so go see him
that's where I was yes Molly did you
decide to go to the play after the
dinner and no no I would have gone to
dinner in a heartbeat
I I had wondered I I had often wondered
what dinner was like when you came into
the city because we you always talked
about them and I had been wanting that
invite I don't know if I consciously
thought it but when he wrote me I was
like ah they invited me I can't go
didn't go by the way is it knowing oh
well you all went but this is maybe this
is where you learned your lesson from
Leno that you don't say in want to be
part of it like you want to be invited
but then you realized maybe if I go
there now I just said it I just said it
now it's I can't go back yeah and my
wife invited you and your husband for a
foursome yes yes and he did one of the
book my wife is so bad around we haven't
done our foursome you know we have not
but when she said that she goes you know
we should have a foursome and your
reaction oh gosh oh yeah I mean she's
got some spirit that she does yes she
does
we have never let her forget that what
we need to do it I will come back guess
the the mean tweet for this is exciting
like this all right here we go Oh Todd
texted me tell Dan I'm not your husband
oh well are not official yeah so did it
just sounds like a business transaction
though was he was your partner scolding
me there we're scolding you I see
where's their exclamation points in
there no there's an ellipses so so very
okay good it's like okay if you want to
correct the record go ahead I'm just
sitting here watching hi
are we still on for our foursome though
that's what I want to know that's
probably why you wanted me to point
clear like I'm still a little bit open a
little bit free okay oh god he's texting
against hey not scolding him okay okay
this is technology is a maze
doesn't he know this is live like that's
kind of unprofessional on Todd's part
there it shows what regard he holds it
does it really does
okay god yes the mean tweets here o
comes okay they these are these are mean
things that were said last night at okay
that we anonymously tweet somebody in
the room and you could be one of sick no
you didn't do that I could but you okay
yeah I could but you don't tweet this
was said to one of the bigger members of
the staff is that fair to say
so somebody who works he's not a Danette
right he said could be add a net we
don't he's a big guy
yeah and so he said what do you
recommend for dessert and someone at the
table said for you probably not having
any no yes that was said that was said
last night at dinner
yes a dinner you missed hoodoos who do
you think said that you got one guess in
it I I think that's you it's again I
don't know where the anger came right
it's not anger but I think it feels like
that
it's not you it's Pauly oh shoot Jeff
that's so obvious yeah so what did you
did sorry I'm sorry
alright see give us give us you hateful
man yes okay I really want to do the
other ones out of the way have time oh
we kick yeah gently we're out of 12 yeah
we got to the best point and we're out
of there some innuendo in O the other
does a lot of innuendo that we just
don't need yeah we yeah you don't need
target let's you know what we're gonna
edit ourselves gonna be mature
look at us growing up yes right in front
of your very eyes
ten years ago anyone had done that no
yeah uh I'm glad you stopped by Jim oh
um it's always great to see you and this
is so fun to be with you the Dan Patrick
show weekday mornings on audience